afternoon ladies and gentlemen it is a
distinct pleasure and honor to introduce
today re tanzi from Harvard Medical
School dr. tansy is professor of
neurology at the Mass General Hospital
has been working out in the field of
Alzheimer's disease for the last 15
years or so and has really made some
seminal contributions to understanding
the jags of Alzheimer's disease Rudy has
recently written a book which you all
are here to listen to what he's going to
tell you about decoding darkness work a
book published with an parson his
colleague dr. tansy received his
bachelor's degree from the University of
Rochester and then his PhD degree in
your science from Harvard Medical School
where he has continued his brilliant
career he has received many very major
important unimportant of wars in your
neurology and neuroscience including the
Metropolitan Life Foundation of war
medical research and attacking tribes
for research from the American Academy
of Neurology their most prestigious
honor so it is with a great pleasure
that we introduce three tansy today to
tell us about his new book thanks thanks
very much Sam I should say that Sam
Sicilia is a good friend of mine so his
generous and kind introduction also
comes from a longstanding friendship and
also as colleagues and the research
against Alzheimer's disease and I'll
talk a little bit about some work that
actually Sam Saudi has also done so
we're here today to discuss what is
obviously an increasingly serious
problem in this country and other
developing countries as well Alzheimer's
disease the most common form of dementia
and the elderly and what I really want
to do today more than anything is share
with you a sense of hope and optimism
and excitement about how far this field
has come in the last 10 to 15 years
driven I would say largely by genetic
findings and genome findings in other
words we've gone from knowing literally
nothing about the cause of this
mysterious disease that robs a person of
the entire memory and personality only
15 years ago we had no idea what causes
disease and now largely through
isolating genes identifying genes that
cause Alzheimer's we're getting a pretty
good idea of the cause and we a more
excitingly there are new drugs that are
in the pipeline and in clinical trials
that I think off a real hope for the
next five years and so in decoding
darkness the book that they are awesome
and I recently published with Perseus
the idea was to write a met a medical
detective story to write this in a way
that could be understood by the
layperson who wants to learn but
Alzheimer's we tried to make it colorful
we included the many researchers who've
dedicated their lives to fighting this
disease and we tell the story from up
from a researchers point of view the ups
and the Downs the emotional
rollercoaster ride you go through doing
this type of research and mainly though
we keep our eye on the big picture which
is what is the outlook for effectively
treating and preventing this terrible
disease so I'm going to use some slides
as a scientist I we become dependent on
slides for presentations it's sometimes
it's better than trying to talk with our
hands although from an Italian family I
know how to talk of my hands too and
I'll begin with just an introduction to
the disease and then now and then I'd
like to also read from some some
passages from the book that are relevant
to what I'm saying
I can get the first light on so
Alzheimer's is as I said the most common
form of dementia I mean dementia is a
general term for losing one's cognitive
abilities excuse me to the point that
everyday life activities are threatened
and challenged it doesn't mean
forgetting where your car keys are it
means repetitive memory loss to the
point that it's just very difficult to
deal with everyday life and it affects
more than four million people in this
country who claims over a hundred
thousand lives per year and it's
currently an age-dependent disease
Alzheimer's increases with frequency as
we age and the stats suggest that about
1 in 20 individuals over the age of 60
have Alzheimer's then every decade after
60 that prevalence rate doubles so you
see one in 10 over 65 excuse me take a
water
up to 1 and 5 over 75 and then the
latest estimates and I think they're
quite reliable say that forty percent
one and two point five forty percent of
individuals over 85 are at least in the
early stages of dementia and most of
this in the elderly at least ninety
percent of it is Alzheimer's the other
percentage can be due to vascular
disease or other types of dementia what
are called the frontal lobe dementia
picks disease but most of it is
Alzheimer's so it's a major problem in
this country other countries patients
can live quite a long time up to 20
years or more so it's a very expensive
disease it costs society 110 billion
dollars per year currently fifty percent
of nursing home patients suffer from
Alzheimer's disease or other age-related
dementia so we really got to get a
handle on this disease because of the
great is a great unmet medical need that
we have in our society and then in terms
of the fact that we hear about the baby
boomers who are aging I guess that
includes me I'm aging I'm a baby boomer
and you know when Alzheimer was dr.
Alzheimer himself back in Germany in the
early 1900s first saw the brain of a
demented woman she was in her 50s and he
defined as disease based on certain
lesions in the brain the disease was
considered rare because we reserve this
name Alzheimer's disease for people who
were showing senile type of
characteristics early in life let's say
under 60 years old but then it was
realized later in the 70s that any
person who is very old who started to
become what we used to say senile could
possibly have the same symptoms the same
pathology in the brain the same lesions
as we saw in this original case of
Alzheimer's that was usually reserved
for young people you know people young
people i mean under under 60 years old
so we grouped together all dimensions
that involve these certain brain lesions
under the rubric of Alzheimer's disease
now life expectancy is increasing
dramatically around the world and
especially in the US and as a result the
incidence of Alzheimer's is rising as
people
grow older and older and you have an
older population there will be more
Alzheimer's disease and this will only
get worse as we expect the baby boomers
heading into their later years we'll see
an explosion of this disease beyond what
we already have this is just a little
some summary of what we know about the
elderly as defined as over 65 and what
we call in the field the oldest old over
85 and interestingly you between 1900
and 1960 there was only a tenfold
increase in those over 65 but that was
quite high compared to twofold increase
for those under 65 and with every new
decade we're seeing that there are more
and more people who fit into this
category of elderly or oldest old so
twenty percent of the population or 70
million people will be over 65 by 2030
and then you consider that up to one in
ten of them will have alzheimer's
disease we're looking at an epidemic
that has started and will get even and
just get worse with time so it's really
very important that the the government
the National Institute of Health
realized that this is the the major
threat to healthy aging especially
healthy brain aging and that we have to
stop this disease for the purposes of
really just even keeping our medical
healthcare system intact is going to get
very expensive so by 2020 there will be
seven million people over 85 by 2040 14
million by 2050 31 million people in
this country alone will be over 85 years
old and we're looking at a forty percent
prevalence of Alzheimer's disease so if
we if you do the math what we see is
that here's two thousand where you have
four million Americans with this disease
by 2050 halfway into the century there
will be 14.3 million cases of
Alzheimer's and the cost to society is
going to be devastating healthcare will
not be able to manage this so something
has to be done relatively quickly and
what I'm here to say and what we say in
decoding darkness is there's hope
there's opt
the research has moved I think in a
model way for diseases that we've made
great progress we have a long way to go
but genetics has driven us to the point
that we have hope and I want to review
for you in unison in lay terms what we
know about this disease now the major
risk factors for Alzheimer's disease are
shown here and like I said number one by
far and away is increased H as we get
older we have higher risk the second
greatest risk factors family history
there is a greater risk of getting
Alzheimer's if you have a first degree
relative or to some extent a second to
be relative with Alzheimer's and that
amount of risk to the family history is
very much related to the age of onset so
when we think about the genetics of
Alzheimer's disease and the genes
involved in Alzheimer's there's this
clear spectrum that would very early age
of onset let's say under 50 years old
the genetics is very robust in this
situation there are genes we know about
that can be inherited from an affected
parent with 50-50 chance and if
inherited will cause the disease with
certainty these are the worst ones the
early onset genes especially when cases
occur under 50 which are quite quite
real that's only 1% of Alzheimer's we
also call cases that occur under 60
early onset but now you enter more of a
gray zone where it doesn't have to be
one of those jeans that you know that is
one hundred percent of the time going to
lead to Alzheimer's like the like the
ones that occur under 50 but 460 it
could be the same as the genes you see
in the more common late onset form of
the disease is twice 60 70 or 80 years
old these are susceptibility genes and
I'm going to get into these we're
instead of having hard hitting gene
mutations that cause of disease with
certainty by inheriting a certain let's
say variant of a gene a change in the
DNA one is that greater risk for getting
the disease so what do I mean by a DNA
variant well it turns out that if you
took all of the genomes all of the DNA
of all the individuals on earth all of
the humans on earth and compared it base
for base you got three billion base
of DNA in each cell making up the human
genome and as you know the human genome
sequence was recently released which is
a great resource and and the agent for
all of us doing molecular research
genetic research and when you combine
all the genomes around the world and
you're asked how many variations are
there in humankind anybody want to take
a guess you can take a guess then 30
million so as I mean there's incredible
diversity into human species we have 30
million different variants among our
three billion bases of DNA between any
two people in this room you have
approximately 3 million differences if
you just compare your genome to the
person next to us about 3 million
differences many of these variations in
the DNA sequence don't matter they are
dead neutral but some of them can cause
a disease like Alzheimer's with
certainty one little base change
Alzheimer's is going to strike with
certainty by 50 years old luckily these
are very rare cases the more common
situation for the genetics of
Alzheimer's disease and the other big
for that the threaten aging besides
Alzheimer's cancer heart disease
together with stroke and diabetes those
are our four main threats to healthy
aging all of them involve a dichotomy so
to speak where you have some gene
variations that are really mutations
they are pathogenic that cause of
disease with certainty they're rare
thank God in a majority of cases of
Alzheimer's cancer heart disease
diabetes instead you see gene variations
that lead to susceptibility you inherit
a certain variant of a DNA and then as a
result your relative risk for the
disease is higher and that was you we
can it's it someday for all these
diseases will have gene chips assuming
genetic privacy is in place and it can
be done with protection you know from
discrimination according to our genome
someday we'll have gene chips for these
major diseases that will determine your
relative risk in society it will say as
a person living in the u.s. due to this
gene chip your relative risk for
Alzheimer's disease as eight folds
higher than the norm and maybe based on
that your HMO will say well here's this
cocktail of drugs at eight fold you've
hit a threshold of danger that you can
start these drugs for prevention of the
disease starting at 40 years old I think
this is where we're going to head with
Alzheimer's in the next five to ten
years as well as cancer diabetes heart
disease and stroke early prediction
through genetics for early prevention of
disease before it even takes root this
is probably gonna be our best bet for
treating these diseases including
Alzheimer's so that would so what do we
need for early prediction we need to
know all the genes involved early
prevention we need to study these genes
ask what goes wrong at the cellular
basis because of this bad gene and then
develop drugs for nipping that in the
bud and not letting it happen and this
is what decoding darkness is about that
this foundation has been set in a big
way or ready for Alzheimer's disease
that we already know of multiple genes
we already have learned from these genes
ideas for stopping the disease and so so
I for one and I think Sam Sicilia here
is well a pretty optimistic about the
future but there's still a lot of work
to do in fact I would argue that
Alzheimer's research is starting now I
mean we've we've now armed herself in
enough information that now we can go
forward and really make a difference and
in terms of preventing and treating this
disease with early prediction so back to
risk factors so family history i just
discussed and the big role of genetics
the main topic of the book but gender
also has an effect women get alzheimer's
more than men now my colleagues would
some of my colleagues would have said
well way my women in general live longer
than men so they're at increased risk
but even when you correct for life
expectancy for women versus men women
get it more and one possibility there is
estrogen during menopause estrogen dips
very low in women at that same agent men
estrogen stays relatively constant and
so one one possibility is that by losing
some estrogen that estrogen is needed to
protect against Alzheimer's now we know
two trials that giving someone an
estrogen pill has not necessarily slow
down the disease or effectively treated
it but that does seem from ever
dimmi ology studies enough data to
suggest that women who are on estrogen
replacement therapy seem to be
relatively protected against Alzheimer's
versus those who work the protective
mechanism estrogen is def is not known
but it is a very active topic of
research in the field head injury head
trauma is a risk factor for Alzheimer's
disease and not just in boxing you know
punch drunk syndrome but I want my
nephew's I have two very athletic
nephews Gregory and Justin who play
every sport there is under the Sun and
when they play soccer I tell them look
if you're going to head the ball make
sure that it's a sunny day in this nice
new ball and the ball is light and it's
not coming to hide from too high in the
air because I used to play soccer in uh
in in school and I remember on those
rainy days and practice when the ball
lost all is polyurethane coating the old
practice balls and they would absorb
rain and water like a sponge and these
things would now weigh about 78 pounds
and then it's coming from 50 odds in the
sky directly into your frontal cortex so
to me that's not a good idea in
retrospect although I just have to hope
I didn't do myself too much damage back
then but I would say you know even as a
message now play it on the safe side
tell you yet your kids to protect their
heads at least against a rainy day in
soccer where you have a heavy object
coming at your head i protect now now
the last risk factor and this is very
controversial but i'll mention it
anyways it says lack of higher education
the reason why this is on the slide is
because there are data that suggests
higher education protects against
alzheimer's disease more moreover and I
think this is very clear staying
intellectually stimulated throughout
your life seeking new areas of knowledge
and education is a great way to protect
yourself against Alzheimer's disease
because if you really look at what goes
wrong in the brain and Alzheimer's why
does one become demented it's not so
much just the loss of nerve cells more
than that is the loss of the connections
that nerve cells make with each other to
create a neural circuit to create mem
in learning these connections between
the nerve cells at the nerve endings are
cause synapses and an Alzheimer's what
correlates best with degree of dementia
is loss of synapses the more synapses
are lost the more demented a person
becomes so it's a very simple you know
logic there than if you make more
synapses or your life you can lose more
before you become demented it's some
people called it the synaptic reserve
hypothesis you know ganking synapses so
just by coming to this talk today you're
protecting yourself against outsiders
story congratulate you on that next
slide up now what factors are associated
with decreased risk well I mentioned
education estrogen it looks like
anti-inflammatory agents especially what
we call NSAIDs non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories these are drugs like
ibuprofen the cut down inflammation it
appears that in the brain once
Alzheimer's gets going there's an
inflammatory response that leads to the
production in the brain of something
called free radicals who probably all
heard free radicals which a little
oxygen based bullets that are used by
some cells in the brain to kill invaders
like bacteria to get into the brain is a
primitive defense system and in
Alzheimer's you can get an inflammatory
response where you have basically
friendly fire the the cells that make
these free radicals look at this
accumulation of this odd material in the
brain that's coming from Alzheimer's
thinks it's an invader and then this
leads to a reaction that then can lead
to the production of free radicals that
then actually kills more nerve cells and
maybe the original toxic agent it was
there so to some extent it looks like n
says a guy Bree profen can be helpful
but you're going to also remember it you
know that these can have effects on the
the the stomach and under GI tract so
you can't just take these you know as
much as you want you have to consult a
physician first some data are emerging
for histamine blockers that's still weak
i won't go into that antioxidants like
vitamin e have been very helpful again
because vitamin d attacks those free
radicals to accumulate in the brain and
exercise has been noted as a protective
so really both mental and physical
exercise seem to be protective
against alzheimer's disease keeping
blood flow and cardiovascular flow hi
now the last one is the most interesting
and I there are papers that say that
smoking is protective and I always
thought that's because people smoke and
they die before they get Alzheimer's
disease but but apparently there's some
protective role for nicotine now this
does not mean go out and smoke to
protect yourself or even to nicorette
gum for that matter but I think it is an
interesting area of research to find out
how nicotine maybe apply maybe providing
some protection every think there's a
there's a trial somewhere look using the
patches the nicotine patches to see if
they help against Alzheimer's we'll have
to wait and see how that how that goes
so what do we see I've been mentioning
these lesions that the characterized
Alzheimer's disease what are they what
did dr. Alzheimer first see when he
looked in the brain of this 51 year old
patient in 1906 well this is what a
normal nerve cell a neuron looks like in
the brain you get the cell body the
nucleus here where the DNA is these
nerve endings come out they connect with
other nerve endings from other nerve
cells create a synapse you create a
complex neural network with really
billions of these connections you become
who you are you have the memories that
you have an Alzheimer's you collect
basically protein-based gunk this is
it's it's it's a highly you know I mean
in lay terms gooey gunk II we say
insoluble debris that's made up of
altered proteins that have been made in
the brain and there's two forms of this
debris that we see in Alzheimer's there
are the senile plaques or the amyloid
plaques that accumulate outside of the
nerve cells like these and inside the
nerve cells you see also these little
twisted pretzel like filaments that we
call tangles and it's the really the
accumulation of both the tangles and the
plaques that you have to see in a
certain amount to say yes this person
who was demented and now we look in
their brain had Alzheimer's in fact you
can't make a confirmed diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease
until you see these lesions on the brain
it's always a probable diagnosis up to
this point the other thing is starting
around 40 years old so this includes me
these plaques and tangles not
accumulating is part of aging we all
start getting them big question is why
do some individuals accumulate these
plaques and tangles so much faster why
do some jeans and some mutations that we
inherit why do some DNA variants that
some of us have predispose us to get in
these lesions faster and and how can we
learn how can we identify those genes to
do this to us learn what they do wrong
and then come up with therapies for
treating or preventing the disease well
that's we've made good progress in that
regard in decoding darkness this is the
topic how we've gone from identifying
genes for Alzheimer's understanding how
these genes work to coming up with some
of the first potentially effective
therapies for this disease that can
treat it and I want to get into that a
bit now so this is really the thing
genetic susceptibility lead into too
many of these lesions leading to
dementia how do we get there how to
restock it okay so at this point I want
to take up I want to read from a passage
from the book and this is from chapter 2
which is entitled the core of the matter
and it starts with a bit of poetry from
Robert Frost from the poem The Secret
sits and it says we danced round and
arranged in suppose but the secret sits
in the middle and nose and the reason
why we chose that quote is because this
is a senile plaque in the brain and the
real secret to what the plaque is made
of and a secret that led to the first
Alzheimer disease gene back in the 80s
and work that I was involved with and as
well as a number of other labs is the
center of the circle the center of the
plaque which is made up of something
called amyloid
and this I want to read a little bit
about how this material was investigated
by a very talented scientist who's now
passed on George Glenn er from San Diego
when George Glenn of glanced down the
barrel of a polarizing microscope one
June morning his swift assessment was
all encompassing his approval immediate
the vivid field of apple green below his
eye was as uniformly bright as he hoped
it would be it was an apple green like
this when you stained the amyloid with
certain dies you get this apple green
color to say yes this is amyloid the
brighter the better the night before
Glenna's technician Connie Wang had
added a stain called Congo red to a
small glob of grayish debris extracted
from blood vessels of brains of average
by Osiris disease the resulting apple
green indicated that after months of
improving their methods the two
scientists had succeeded in isolating in
a rich sample of amyloid amyloid which
Glenn of viewed as quote one hell of a
nasty substance as the gummy protein
that abnormally relentlessly accumulates
in the brains of Alzheimer's the older
and younger scientists had rested a bit
of it free from other brain material
this was definite progress but as Glenna
was keenly aware it was a far cry from
their bigger goal which was to decipher
the proteins component parts its amino
acids well Glennon will go on to do this
and what this means is that somehow what
Glenna had to do back in the early 80s
was take this gunk break it down
dissolve it so that he could analyze
exactly what protein is in there
proteins are made up of strings of amino
acids just like you can sequence the
human genome for bases of DNA you can
sequence a protein for the sequence of
amino acids in fact DNA bases of DNA in
a gene encode for amino acids in a
protein was the way we make up proteins
so when Glenna did this he was able to
publish an amino acid sequence and this
allowed me as a graduate student then as
well as other laboratories in this
country and around the world so
simultaneously published in 1987 that
there was a gene that made this
terial that sat on the smallest little
chromosome in our genome these are all
the chromosomes spread out in the
nucleus in our genome the way the DNA is
packed and the smallest little
chromosome chromosome 21 was the one
that contained the amyloid gene the
amyloid gene would then become known as
the amyloid precursor protein a PP so we
call it now the APPG in rather than the
amyloid gene just a note here when you
look at these chromosomes it's amazing
how nature has figured out a way to take
long strings of DNA that would really
spread across the country and coil them
up into such elegant little packages
that you get chromosomes that can fit
into the tiny nucleus of a cell that
never ceases to amaze me one way to
think about how this is done is when
you're in your office in here your
telephone coil gets gets to coiled up
and it really bugs you because you try
to answer the phone and the whole phone
goes flying off the desk onto the like I
do and then you lose the call well this
happens to me a lot I finally got one of
these little devices to fix that but
basically this this is called
supercoiling and it happens to telephone
coils all the time this would DNA does
is its regularly coils in a relaxed
state as you keep twisting it and
twisting it it gets bunched up into a
ball and then there are proteins that
then hold all these together in these
very exquisite little forms we call roma
somas which is shown here and chromosome
21 was the was identified as containing
the amyloid gene well what would happen
after that was up about pretty exciting
you know we said hey maybe we have an
alzheimer gene here well in the
beginning we didn't well he first
isolated the gene we couldn't find any
mutations in the gene and alzheimer
patients was very frustrating this one
hour for years and then finally in the
early 90s a group in England finally
found a family in which they had a
mutation in the amyloid or the APPG so
the first I'll summer gene mutation was
found at that time by an English team of
scientists when that happened we were
all very excited and if we this is a
slide it just summarizes the
consequences of what can you do when you
isolate a disease gene well first of all
there's improve diagnosis you can do you
know if you have a gene to contain
mutation that causes a disease with
certainty even though it's really rare
infant and you can you can you can track
it into families where you see it and if
the person wishes if proper genetic
counseling is giving legal safeguarding
of the information privacy is there you
can do pre-symptomatic diagnosis but I
think equally important is now you can
start to work with this gene one of the
first people to work with the APPG with
sam sicilia looking at how that what was
the protein that this gene made how is
this protein handles how did you get
from this normal protein in the brain
and in the body to have it you know
manipulate it down into this gunk we
call amyloid how did how did this
pathological conversion take place and
Sam played a big role in figuring that
out as well as other labs around the
country and this understanding disease
mechanism had begun with the first off
I'm a gene mutation we were on our way
to understanding hardest diseases caused
and of course is also ethical dilemmas
well you know prediction without in
Parliament you know do you want to
predict a disease in someone and then
leave them hanging saying yes you have
the mutation the odds are a hundred
percent you're going to get this disease
by 60 years old there's nothing we can
do I mean that's a tough call I think
for that reason a lot of people even
with the more robust genetic form the
early onset form don't want to know
because there's nothing they can do yet
some of them want to know for family
planning and financial planning and as
with the potential for collateral damage
if the file genetic information is not
protected and kept private we can find
all kinds of problems with health
insurance possibly your employment so
it's very I think the government has to
take a much stronger stand move much
much more on genetic privacy acts to
make sure that they cannot be
discrimination according to our genetic
code we can't help the genome were born
with I actually recommended several
times to and to add to race color and
Creed DNA sequence I mean you know race
color and freedom more or less political
definitions of
of humankind but if you really want to
protect us against discrimination go
right down to our genome and say that
cannot be discrimination according to
the genome put it in our in our
Constitution and amendments and and then
be done with it then we can do early
prediction early prevention plans
without worrying about collateral damage
well we'll see how this all turns out
now since that time three different
early onset genes for Alzheimer's have
been found as the APPG non little
chromosome 21 to other genes have been
found they call the priests in dylan's
or ps1 and ps2 chromosome 14 and
chromosome 1 this is the biggest
chromosome this is the smallest
chromosome they're actually numbered
according to size one is the biggest the
smallest should be 22 but in the
original calculation somebody blew it
actually 21 is the smallest but they
kept the nomenclature the same just for
consistency but these are the three
early onset genes and what they have in
common is a couple of things first of
all mutations in these jeans only cause
about 1% of Alzheimer's tiny percentage
but the mutations here and there are
about 100 all tolls right now that we
know about most of them are and ps1
they're about 80 here about 10 here 10
or 12 here and five or six here these
mutations cause the disease with
certainty when inherited and use the
onset son 250 for two of the mutations
in PS 1 onset occurs in the 20s in fact
there's been a most recently a family
found with a ps1 mutation that causes
Alzheimer's as he's starting at 15 years
old if you can believe it as 15 so these
are the most robust mutations now one
might say hey wait a minute but these
mutations only account for one percent
of the disease why bother study in them
well it's because these are the only
mutations we know about which when
inherited guarantee the disease so if
you want to learn about the biology of
Alzheimer's and what goes wrong these
are the main jeans you want to study and
the odds are that whatever is going
wrong as a result of these rare gene
mutations is going to be applied to the
more common late onset forms of
Alzheimer's disease so this is what was
has been done and the second main thing
they have in common is in the
sorry the I thought I thought it was the
next slide and just go ahead a bit shown
in this slide and that is mutations in
all three of these genes ap PE ps1 and
ps2 all do the same thing they increase
the accumulation the production of a
small protein in the brain to recall a
beta stands for amyloid beta when George
Glenn ur first dissolved the amyloid
core of the plaque he found this small
little peptide peptides of small protein
and then based on the sequencing of that
small protein too he provided the field
in the 80s when we and other groups were
able to isolate the gene that makes it
we found that there was a big protein
showing like here like a stick call a PP
and the little piece that makes up the
plaque called a beta is embedded in the
big approaching so we have a big protein
but a tiny little protein embedded
inside of it and what we found with the
first three Alzheimer genes the early
onset genes what they all have in common
is they increase the probability that
you're going to have a an enzyme come in
and clip here and then clip here so you
actually release this little red piece
so if you picture a piece of rope and
you've taken a magic marker made one
little piece of it red and that little
red piece if you snip it out of the rope
with two clips if you get enough of
those they accumulate to form a senile
plaque that's basically what's going on
in Alzheimer's so what this toeless is
that hey we have three different
Alzheimer jeans and they all do the same
basic thing you make too much of this
particular little protein that we call a
beta 42 because it's 42 amino acids long
and normally if you just make this
amount of it the brain gets rid of it it
clears it as a matter of course but if
you make too much of it it starts to
stick to itself and now you start
forming these gooey globs of amyloid
that you see in the senile plaques so
this told the the pharmaceutical
companies in the biotech companies hey
here's our target for a drug the genes
have given us a target what we need to
do is don't let those little clips
her in the piece of rope so if you can
find the enzymes that clip the little
protein out of the big one here and here
and then stop those enzymes the same way
you hear an aids about protease
inhibitors protease azhar the enzymes
that clip other proteins protease is our
molecular scissors that clip proteins if
you could find a molecular scissors
these this class of enzyme called
protease that that frees the little red
peptide from this parent protein you'd
have a chance to treat the disease so
that was the first big step i think in
terms of how we went from jeans to
potential effective drugs is that now we
we know of trials going on to four
compounds that do prevent drug compounds
that do prevent the clipping that
produces the small protein that makes up
the amyloid plaque now just go back a
moment i wanted to get into a little bit
about therapies now and I had this slide
out it doesn't show up because of the
light but if you can if you could read
this I was on vacation in Hawaii and I
picked up this pink bottle and you can't
see this but it says no ad so I said oh
here you go just rub this on and you get
rid of Alzheimer's disease ended up with
tanning lotion and why did we call
tanning lotion no ad I have no idea but
it would be very nice to to have
something like this so this is just my
introduction into what do we what are we
doing for treating this disease and this
is this would be the end of my
presentation after this right now we
have two drugs that are on the market
then used for Alzheimer's aricept and
exelon and both of these drugs have the
same basic idea that treating a symptom
of the disease they're not curing the
disease they're not preventing the
disease what they're doing is they're
helping to maintain the memory that use
that you that you can have their words
these are called cholinesterase
inhibitors what these drugs do is this
if you consider this as a nerve ending
and another nerve ending here on your
forming a synapse so then the nerve
style connected here is telling this
nerve cell what to do and this is all
part of a circuit from memory and
learning well too
do this there's these small little
chemicals neural chemicals or
neurotransmitters in this case called
acetylcholine and this nerve ending
releases that the sto choline to this
one these little spheres here and this
nerd then this way the neuron tells us
neuron what to do well in alzheimer's
disease many of the nerve cells that are
responsible for making this particular
chemical osteo choline that's used for
the transmission of memory the chemical
transmission of memory die and you don't
have enough asset to your choline so
what this with the drugs that are out
there do is they try to preserve the
cult they asked your calling that's
already there they block its breakdown
so these little spheres will get broken
down by something called cholinesterase
and these drugs block that particular
protease now I think we're grateful that
we have exelon and we have our recept as
a treatment elisa treats a symptom it
helps some patients sometimes just
temporarily many you may have more
experience with how well these drugs
work they're not a treatment they were
band-aid but better than nothing but
they're a band-aid on a gushing wound so
where do we go how do we get to from
what we learned from genetics to
effective treatments and it gets back
again to this diagram that the next
class of Alzheimer drugs that will have
a great chance of working I think will
be those that stop the production of
amyloid now I should also state that
this is a little controversial some in
the field think that the amyloid plaque
is as a consequence of the disease it's
a side product and they may be right the
actual plaque that I showed you earlier
that forms in the brain may just be the
brains way of dealing with all this
extra little protein da baited it's
being made and spit out by nerve cells
and it may actually be a good thing to
have a plaque and get rid of this stuff
so it doesn't accumulate you know
sporadically is all over the brain but
what we now know is that on the way to a
plaque these little proteins da betas
can form clusters they can form what
would a little
not like and rope like structures that
float around in the brain as aggregates
and these seem to be toxic these seem
when they interact with nerve cells to
be toxic so it's not so much the plaques
that are already submitted a shin area
it might take 10 years to form that I
worry about in this so called amyloid
hypothesis the the bad guy is going to
be the initial little clusters of this
little protein a beta as its forming
these little not like a rope like
structures that are going to be
free-floating as little fibrils in the
brain before they get sucked up into a
plaque these are the guys we need to
target based on toxicity experiments so
how do you do that okay if you want to
get rid of something there's two ways to
do it so if you have a sink that's
filling with water and overflowing onto
the bathroom floor there are two ways to
deal with it you can turn off the faucet
let's say the faucet has a drip or in
the case of some mutations the force is
just constantly running so you can try
and turn off the faucet turn off the
water that's what the drugs do for
example bristol-myers squibb has a trial
for an inhibitor of the enzyme that
releases this small protein so you're
turning off the production of the
protein that's what the early onset
genes have taught us to do the other way
you can do it is try to enhance its
clearance in other words the other way
to help that that drew that sync'd it's
over filling with water is pull out the
plug let the water clear down the drain
so there are also companies that are
trying to work with clearance of amyloid
from the brain clear this stuff away now
I think ultimately you're going to have
a cocktail of drugs for this disease
where some of the drugs would be like
the aricept and exelon that help
maintain memory help maintain the
neurotransmitters that are being
attacked other drugs will slow the
production of the a beta so you have
fewer of these toxic aggregates other
drugs will clear that the aggregates
that are already there the amyloid has
already been laid down you'll have drugs
are clear it away and one drug in this
insight really a drug but one approach
here you may have heard about is the
vaccine approach so our company called
Elan
in San Francisco formerly Athena what
they are doing now is injecting the
amyloid into they did this originally in
mice and they got good results and doing
a trial where they inject the amyloid
into human and the human has an immune
response against the amyloid and this
seems to help clear the amyloid away
from the brain mechanism isn't exactly
known in fact it was a big surprise that
it worked here was a you know and now we
have to hope and if would have called
phase 1 trials for safety that the
vaccine will be safe we don't know I
mean anytime you inject one of our own
proteins into the body you can have a
you know an autoimmune response you can
make antibodies against your own
proteins you can you can you can have
but a side effect of assefa lightest in
the brain these are all dangers we have
to think about with this technique
that's why they're doing a safety trial
and so far from what we've been told
from elon is that they haven't been
problems that the patients have been
able to tolerate the vaccine so far but
more more trials needed same thing with
the the bristol-myers squibb trial where
they tryin to block the production of
the of the actual a beta peptide there
in a safety phase where they're trying
to see if they can treat people with
this drug and make sure that they don't
get the side effects so those are two of
the trials that are going on now this
slide isn't showing up but I just wanted
to end I'll just go to my last slide in
terms of where are we going in the
future of this disease well so far even
though it sounds like we've made a lot
of progress in terms of identifying four
or five at the alzheimer genes we know
that ninety percent 90 ninety percent of
Alzheimer genetics is still unaccounted
for a Bowie for is a risk allele the
apoE gene on chromosome 19 is a
late-onset risk factor e for predisposes
individuals to two things heart disease
and Alzheimer's especially if you
inherit a copy of e4 apoe4 from a mother
and your father you have to leave fours
so this is just an you know another
example of DNA variation
we're for the April Eugene there are
three major variants two three and four
based on amino acid changes that come
from DNA base changes now what is the
link well II for predisposes people to
high cholesterol and high cholesterol as
you know is bad for you four is a risk
factor for heart disease and with
increasing data increasing studies show
that cholesterol high cholesterol is
also risk factor for Alzheimer's and in
fact has now been an experimental link
shown between cholesterol and increased
amyloid production in the brain although
we don't yet know how it's happening so
my guess is that if you have you know if
the April etest is done now one should
also think about that cholesterol that
apoe is probably not working in a vacuum
that if you do any for tests and you
carry four which is n a risk factor it's
also important to look at whether
cholesterol is high and one study that's
being done is trying to figure out
whether why certain individuals can
inherit efore even in two copies never
get Alzheimer's disease up so 90 years
old others keck inherit to ephors and
they have Alzheimer's by 60 well I think
what we have to look at there is
cholesterol because it may be too
certain individuals have to ephors but
their exercise and their diet takes care
that cholesterol or they have other
genetic factors to counter the
increasing cholesterol so this is what I
would like to see in the future is a
more of a link to how cholesterol is
playing a role with this one genetic
susceptibility gene apoe4 now apoe4 is
present and twenty-five percent of the
population twenty-five percent of people
wanted for carry a copy of e for an
Alzheimer's is present in fifty percent
of patients double the prevalence of
just the average population but even
though it's in fifty percent of patients
it doesn't necessarily have to cause the
disease you can inherit e4 and never get
the disease so it's actual contribution
to the genetics is not fifty percent
because it's not guaranteed to give you
the disease is more around ten percent
that's called the attributable risk
so what we know then is if you take the
early onset jeans a PP priests in all in
one piece of land to you take a bow eat
put them all together still we have to
we still have yet to I to identify
ninety percent of the genetic factors on
Alzheimer's and what we've learned so
far is that every time we've gotten a
new gene for this disease not not only
have we come closer to genetic testing
for early prediction but you've learned
a whole lot about how to treat the
disease and so I think this is the
course we have to keep on identify the
genes given the people like Sam Sicilia
figure out how these genes work look at
cell biology look at the mechanism of
pathogenesis come up with ideas for
drugs and if we're lucky over we're
going to see a nice dovetail of a
reliable genetic test for Alzheimer's
which we do not have yet with the
exception of these rare cases that occur
under 50 which is one percent we don't
have a genetic test yet even the April
etest is not to be used for prediction
is used just to get a better idea of
what it whether it might be Alzheimer's
disease so we need still need a genetic
test to be developed my lab and other
labs are doing that and based on the
jeans you already have in the new genes
that were about to to have hopefully
over the next few years get more ideas
for what proteins are involved what's
going wrong with these proteins what are
the biological pathways in the brain to
go wrong and how can we interfere with
that and get drugs that help I think you
know in decoding darkness the last the
chapter 12 is a gamble for hope okay
many of us are betting on the amyloid
hypothesis I got to say that in decoding
darkness were very biased toward the
amyloid hypothesis working we think that
if you nip the amyloid in the brain you
try to get rid of a beta through
clearance or you try to lowers
production as the trials are now doing
is another trial I didn't mention down
on Australia from a company called prana
that's also trying to lower the a beta
the amyloid in the brain working through
a different pathway involving a copper
and zinc you know there are many
different companies and too many to
mention that are attacking us from all
different angles but i think the
successful companies would be the ones
that in one way around
other can reduce the accumulation of
amyloid in the brain either by lowering
production or increasing its clearance
either way and they're on the way and
then the genetic tests hopefully will
predict who needs these drugs are early
in life for for stopping the disease
from ever taking root and I just want to
just end we're just reading to last
passages from the book and I one of them
is just about AD and it in the horror of
AD and this is from the chapter called
gone fishing what makes us fear
Alzheimer's so erase memory we
instinctively realize and a person's
very humanist is cancelled out our
reality is basically our memory surmises
James McGaha prominent neuro scientists
at the University of California Irvine
who specializes in learning a memory
quote we believe our existence is so
continuous so seamless but really it's
only a half a second long everything
that happened a second before his memory
and the next second what we believe will
happen is also memory either God memory
as the bridge between the past and
present and future end of quote due to
memory then we live in a delusional sort
of way projecting a temporal and spatial
reality that is far far more extensive
than a dot of time and space we pass
through at any given moment take away
that delusional continuity between past
and future as well as time and space and
you begin to gain a sense of an Islamic
patients terribly limited world as John
Bailey wrote an elegy for iris about his
wife novelist Iris Murdoch before she
died of Alzheimer's quote she feels a
vacancy that frightens her by its lack
of dimension end of quote now what is
the hope for the future and this is
along the lines of what I was just
talking about early prediction early
prevention in the future the ultimate
indispensable diagnostic might be a
person's genotypic profile we use
genotypic as another word for genetic
someone's entire genome might be put on
a biochip that is outfitted with all the
mutations and polymorphisms known to
cause Alzheimer's their DNA would either
bind or not buy into those danger points
a computer scan of the chip would
handily reveal any DNA defects doing
away with the time-consuming methods
that currently allow us to SS of persons
gene alleles the resulting profile might
relate other valuable pieces of
information such as a person's overall
risk for Alzheimer's the time window of
onset in which treatments will be most
effective as well as which treatments
might carry side side effects adverse
events a futuristic vision for
conquering Alzheimer's wraps around the
powerful combination for genetic
screening o is accompanied by counseling
and stringent safeguards and preventive
drugs optimized for a person's genome a
foundation is being laid right now for
such an eventuality the year might be
2010 or later a person with a family
history of Alzheimer's or perhaps no
family history at all decides to be
assessed for his or her predisposition
to Alzheimer's family history is
reviewed a genetic profile is obtained
levels of a beta tau and perhaps other
relative proteins are measured a
baseline measurement of certain brain
regions is retrieved through imaging
using MRI should this work up sound an
alarm with just one magic bullet
available a vaccine for instance that
would obviously be the therapy of choice
but more likely a range of treatments
would be required and dispensed
according to a person's age genetic
profile and disease stage should
fibrillar a beta turn out to be
Alzheimer's demon a daily anti a beta
cocktail might be described that what's
a beta in a number of ways by inhibiting
the protease activities by blocking
aggregation by promoting its clearance
by mid-century new estimates warn the
world may contain 45 million awesomer
patients three times as many as there
are now bring on effective drugs and a
good many of those individuals just
might be able to experience their golden
years with a clear mind and sound
recollection so let's just hope that
hard work will get us there and that we
can maintain our optimism and I'll stop
there and take any questions
thank you between Alzheimer's and I
haven't seen the study but if you could
tell me more about it I haven't seen it
so I'm sorry what was that what was the
main crux of the
a much shorter period of time than some
of us have thought that is short yeah I
I would be interestin see I must be I
haven't seen later an issue of her in a
journal but my book is reviewed in that
same issue so I better get a copy anyway
yes do you know of any way that stem
cell research might increase the
acetylcholine production well
technically you know if you could have a
stem cell modified to produce more sto
choline that would be helpful right now
since the stem cell research that has
been in the news from San Diego is based
on nerve growth factor it's based on
providing growth factors because we
growth factors you can get all kinds of
potentially good things happening a
nerve cell I have you know some
reservations about stem cell research I
think eventually it will be helpful it
will be useful but I'm not convinced so
far that we're there that we can you
know put neuronal stem cells into the
brain and get instant results we have to
you know you think about the the neural
network you know these nerve cells have
been hanging around together for a long
time they've all made friends they've
made connections it was a very intricate
system of increasing and decreasing
synapses so if you just throw you know a
bunch of rogue nerve cells in there and
say okay go do it you know enter the
network you know it's it can be varied
you can imagine how difficult that might
be so I think we still need to learn a
lot more before we can effectively
facilitate our own neural circuits by
entering new stem cells into the brain
especially if you want to replace
neurons now if you just want to put stem
cells in to make factors you might be
missing like growth factors or
neurotransmitters there's still a caveat
because you don't want to make too much
I mean if you make too much of any
growth factor you have to worry about
cancer and these types of things or on
cell for lightest so I'm you know I wish
the best of it I'm hopeful but I think
we need a lot more research on stem
cells before we're going to see a big
impact on Alzheimer's disease
diacetyl colleen is there any way to
increase the production of it yeah
they're in fact I should say that there
are pharmaceutical companies around the
world that are using next-generation
strategies for increasing osteo choline
not only by blocking its rape town by
enhancing the receptors that take
Castillo choline enhancing their
activity by having compounds that can
mimic Castillo choline to get these same
receptors stimulated for neural
transmission so there are other various
ways people are working on that I think
will come out before will see us a stem
cell approach but that may very well be
we may very well see a stem cell
approach fast you're calling ten years
from golf all I know the side that you
showed the demonstrated the mechanism of
a beta was based on the early onset
genes is there evidence that
demonstrates is the same mechanism for
late-onset are you messing with that
hypothesis that's an excellent question
in case I didn't make that I might have
gone over that too quickly so the early
onset genes seem to have in common that
they increase the production of a beta
42 the main component of amyloid you get
more of it made from the parent molecule
the late onset genes like a Bowie and a
gene that we are working on dits still
controversial as an alzheimer gene was
called alpha 2 macroglobulin a2m both of
these genes are associated not with
increased production so far of the a
beta but decreased clearance and in most
studies you know where the Alzheimer
genes have been introduced into my so
they get amyloid and some limited
Alzheimer's pathology in their brains
one can see that if you mix and match
some of these late-onset ahsan machines
and you affect the rate of clearance you
affect the rate of aggregation so you do
see some evidence from from at least the
animal studies that these late-onset
genes affect more the rate of clearance
the rate of aggregation as opposed to
the rate of production an amyloid you
guess you know you're always going to
keep tasting separate production of its
principal building block the a beta
peptide
how fast it aggregates and we know that
metals play a role they're zinc and
copper seem to affect aggregation rate
and then once it's made its plopped down
on the brain as an aggregate is it going
to be cleared away is it going to float
around and wreak havoc on nerve cells is
it going to be sequestered into a plaque
all three of these have to be
categorized separately when you think
about drug intervention yes one of the
one of the prospects of getting
information for the genetics of
late-onset Alzheimer's during the next
10 years 15 years comparable to the
rather good information that we have for
early Alzheimer's early onset alzheimer
so the the the late onset Alzheimer's
gene quest is a lot more difficult
because the genes involved in late-onset
Alzheimer's mainly carry variations that
don't guarantee the disease is going to
strike so the early onset genes in a way
were much much easier because first of
all the disease struck so early in life
that you could find families with many
members who are affected because they're
not dying of other causes they get into
disease or you know before 50 in many
cases so you have large families to work
with and you know that when the disease
mutations inherited in those rare cases
they get the disease with certainty so
you can do the genetics with a little
bit more reliability but when you're
trying to track a disease gene that may
have may not have been inherited that
may may not cause the disease when is
inherited the whole analysis gets far
more complex well luckily new genetic
analytical techniques have been
developed or and being developed for
dealing what we could what we call
complex genetic disorders like
Alzheimer's diabetes all the psychiatric
disorders schizophrenia autism so that
we are making progress and my lab and
other labs around the world have carried
out what we call genome screens we
screen the whole human genome to find
out where in the genome the other
Alzheimer genes may sit and the whole
discovery process is what I described is
going from where to
to how first we find out where the
disease gene is in the genome that gives
us a location we call it a locus we
don't know what the gene is yet then you
have to do a whole lot of work a whole
lot of sequencing of all the genes in
that little area where you think the
gene might reside and you have to
sequence that gene and affected people
with the disease from families and find
a mutation and you find lots of DNA
variation some of them are just neutral
you never know which one really is
causing the disease and see more
difficult if it may or may not cause the
disease when inherited you know if it's
questionable but you have to take your
best guess do good biology call your
friends Sam you know who does good cell
biology try and get an idea of what the
gene mutation is and I should also say
that in my you know research unit at
Mass General you know my lab primarily
does genetics but I'm surrounded by
other people who do excellent cell
biology molecular biology and
biochemistry people who can talk to Sam
and collaborate with him and figure out
how to go from the what to the how other
words once you've gone to where the gene
is what is the gene whether the
mutations you want to know how those
mutations cause a disease you need to do
old fashioned biology the genome is not
going to help you anymore so in that
case you know we have a number of
excellent labs and there are you know
great labs around the world and in this
country that do this type of work and
then once you get the pathogenic
mechanism what pathway is going wrong
now you can try to target the disease
process with a drug intervention screen
for drugs do you want to add anything to
that samer okay why is my friend yes
patients Alzheimer's patients who are on
the two existing drugs to take those two
existing drugs do they live considerably
longer than patients who don't take
these drugs or doesn't unravel tea isn't
longevity affected by it it's
interesting question as to whether the
current Alzheimer drugs increased
longevity you know what they do